the more you can connect it to a real
human being
the more you will feel it
um and i'll prove it to you
stalin said
stalin said the death of
uh one man is a tragedy in the death of
a million as a statistic
right so
i'll tell you two stories both are true
um
uh
right now what we are witnessing in
europe is
a horrible event of this war in ukraine
and we see a proud people standing up to
defend themselves
against this oppressive regime that is
invading their country unnecessarily
and
the conservatives uh uh estimates now
are you know uh i i think the last one i
read was about you know 5 000
uh
men and women killed
rising up against this despotic regime
right that's a fact
those are numbers now let me tell you
another story
i have a friend
named cammy who
lives in san clemente california and she
was driving home from work one day and
she
as she turned the corner she came upon a
car accident that had just happened
where a
17 year old driver had hit an 18 year
old pedestrian
and this 18 year old girl was
lying on the street her leg at a 90
degree angle
unconscious and the ambulances hadn't
arrived yet
cami pulled her car over
and got out and sat with the girl and
just sat with her until the paramedics
arrived
eventually the paramedics arrived and
took her away
and
a few days later she was curious what
happened to that girl she went online
onto the blotter and found out that that
18 year old girl had died
okay what made you feel more
thousands of people who died standing up
against a
oppressive regime to defend their
lifestyle and their democracy
or one 18 year old girl who got hit by a
car in
california that's my point which is when
you tell a story about a specific person
you feel it way more
than telling statistics of all the
people you held helped or all the homes
you've sold i don't care about how many
homes you've sold or how many families
you've helped tell me about the one you
remember
you know that's the one you tell
and when somebody says what can you do
for me
i've lived in this neighborhood for 30
years and i have a greater knowledge of
this neighborhood than anybody else and
i've sold more houses and i'll get you
the best deal and then you get a cynical
bastard like me who goes your business
model encourages you not to get me the
best deal
i mean that's the way i think i
apologize because you want to keep the
price up because that's what makes you
more money like i know like i get it
right it's like therapists don't want to
get you better because they get paid by
the hour
if they did flat fee we'd all be
fine uh
but if you if you walk in and say and
somebody says why should i why should i
do business with you
right you'd be like three years ago i
met this family the joneses oh what a
wonderful couple two kids
lucy and george and just the best and
you tell a story about what you got to
know about them and what they were
looking for and how you spent the time
with them
and people will relate their experience
to the joneses not to the 55 houses
you've sold or the 30 years you've been
in business because i don't care
i just need one
uh and so the more you can tell a
specific story the more people can feel
it